424 milliards d'euros c'est la facture
astronomique de l'actrice du coc vite
pour les finances publiques françaises
jusqu'en 2022 un chiffrage a donné par
olivier dussopt aps le ministre des
comptes publics alors même que
l'épidémie continue de sévir
qu'y a t'il exactement dans ces 4 124
milliards correspond t'il vraiment la
réalité pourquoi cette somme nous est
annoncé maintenant c'est l'objet de
l'édito échos ce soir de jacques sapir
alors bon soir jacques que faut-il
penser de ceux ci fera je pense que
c'est vrai que chiffrage j'ai du mal à
le dire même 424 milliards d'euros ça
fait peur
oui bonsoir c'est fanny oui
effectivement c'est une somme qui a été
annoncé par le ministre des comptes
publics que monsieur olivier dussopt et
alors c'est une somme qui est censé
couvrir à la fois l'année 2020 l'année
2021 et l'année 2022 alors évidemment on
peut être sûr de 2020 puisque les
comptes ont été arrêtés 2021 évidemment
on est en train de dépenser cet argent
2022 on n'y est pas encore
donc on voit qu'il ya évidemment des des
choses qui sont sûres et puis les choses
qui le sont beaucoup moins
dans ce chiffrage après on peut penser
aussi que en faisant ce chiffrage
le ministre des comptes publics fait
plus de la politique que de la
comptabilité
alors jacques de quoi est-on sûr
actuellement
alors on a d'abord ceux qui étaient
dépensés l'année dernière en 2020 bon ça
on connaît les sommes
c'est à peu près 150 8 milliards de ça
on est absolument sûr après il y à ce
qui est prévu de dépenser pour l'année
qui vient pour l'année dans lequel nous
sommes donc 171 milliards et là il ya
déjà des petits problèmes parce que
évidemment cette somme elle inclut quoi
elle inclut le chômage partiel
elle inclut le fonds de solidarité et
inclut aussi le plan de relance sauf que
eh ben il ya de grandes incertitudes que
ce soit sur le plan de relance sur le
chômage partiel voire même sur le plan
de solidarité et donc tout ça évidemment
ce n'est pas très très très sûr en tous
les cas pour 2021 a pas très sûr pour
quelle raison il ya plusieurs raisons
première raison est évidemment la
question des pg ou s'ouvrir les les
prêts garantis par l'état
on ne sait pas en réalité si les
entreprises pourront effectivement les
rembourser ça va courir sur 2021 sur
2022 est donc évidemment si elles ne
peuvent pas les rembourser
il faudra immédiatement que l'état se
substitue à elle est donc ça fera des
sommes en plus
deuxième point le plan de relance alors
dans le plan de relance
d'abord il ya une partie des 100
milliards qui ne sont pas de l'argent
dépensé qui sont tout simplement des
déductions fiscales
est-ce que ça a été inclus dans la somme
ou pas s'est il d'abord eu une question
qu'on peut se poser
et puis il ya des sommes qui étaient
déjà prévus par exemple dans le c ur de
la santé que l'on a rajouté dans le plan
de relance est ce qu on a continué à les
compter deux fois dans le budget bon là
aussi il ya de très grands l'incertitude
sur l'ensemble des sommes qui seraient
dépensées dans cette année mais jacques
comment fait le gouvernement pour
arriver à ce total de 424 milliards
c'est assez facile si vous voulez ce que
fait le gouvernement bon il prend les
158 milliards qui ont été dépensés
l'année dernière il rajoute les 171
milliards qu'il a prévu de dépenser et
qu'il est d'ailleurs effectivement
entrait en partie de dépenser cette
année et il y ajoute 95 milliards pour
2022 et là c'est 95 milliards
honnêtement on ne sait pas ce qu'il en
sera ça peut être moins dans certains
cas par exemple admettons que l'épidémie
soit complètement contrôlé à cet automne
et à mon avis les dépenses seront
nettement moins importants comme ça peut
être nettement plus si on a une épidémie
qui court jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et si on a des gros problèmes
d'insolvabilité au niveau des
entreprises qui ont pris ce qu'on
appelle des prêts garantis par l'état
des pg e ce qui obligerait comme je les
dis l'état à se substituer à l or
justement quelles sont celles
en politique alors les raisons
politiques qu'il y a si vous voulez dans
cet effet d'annonce parce qu on voit
bien ce qu'a fait olivier dussopt ben ça
ça relève de l'effet d'annoncé à mon
avis elles sont deux la première raison
à écouter c'est une évidence
emmanuel macron est d'ores et déjà en
campagne pour sa réélection en 2022
c'est tout à fait clair et de ce point
de vue là eh bien je pense qu'il faut
apprécier ce montant de 4 124 milliards
dans le cadre des annonces qui seront
faites dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que on se rappel
l'année dernière
emmanuel macron avait annoncé en mars
2020 qu'il ferait tout ce qu'il faut
pour soutenir les français et soutenir
l'activité économique
quoi qu'il en coûte et bien c'est une
manière de montrer justement que ce quoi
qu'il en coûte
eh bien il a été poussé jusqu'au bout et
qu'on a vraiment mis de l'argent pour
soutenir l'activité
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait évident
mais vous sur ce point vous avez des
doutes
oui effectivement effectivement si vous
voulez quand on regarde les sommes qui
ont été dépensées au simple niveau du
gouvernement c'était au niveau
budgétaire
et bien qu est-ce qu on constate on
constate que la france oui bien sûr
elles à la dépense et on le voit la plus
dépensé que la moyenne de l'union
européenne mais elle a nettement moins
dépensé que l'allemagne que l'autriche
et surtout que le royaume uni ou que les
états unis et je signale que la les
sommes qui sont indiqués pour les états
unis
ce sont des données du fonds monétaire
international elle n'inclut pas le plan
qui sera prévu qui sera en fait voté au
mois de juillet et qui devrait rajouter
2200 milliards de dollars à la facture
donc on voit bien là aussi qu' il ya un
très gros déséquilibre entre ceux qui
étaient dépensés en france et ce qui a
été dépensé dans un certain des autres
pays on sait bien jacques aussi qu' il
n'y a pas que les dépenses budgétaires
l'état aussi garanti de nombreux prêts
oui vous avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie c'est tout à fait exact c'est
par exemple le cas des prêts garantis
aux entreprises c'est le cas des pg e
mais là encore si on fait la somme à si
on additionne aux dépenses budgétaires
les mesures monétaires c'est-à-dire
l'argent qui est prêté ou ou qui est en
garanties de prêts par l'état alors on
voit que la situation de la france
montrent un peu surtout par rapport à la
moyenne de l'union européenne mais qu'
elle ne monte pas tant que ça par
rapport à l'allemagne par rapport à
l'italie aussi qui en a fait beaucoup
plus que nous par rapport au royaume uni
et probablement par rapport aux états
unis si on y inclut la l'ensemble des
dépenses qui ont été annoncés alors
qu'il s'agisse du plan byden de soutien
à l'économie du mois de mars dernier
ou qu'il s'agisse du futur plan de
relance qui sera voté donc cet été en
conclusion que faut-il penser donc de ce
chiffre de 4 124 milliards d'euros si
vous voulez la déclaration du ministre
elle est intéressante elle est
intéressante pour 3 pour trois choses
alors la première chose c'est évidemment
on voit bien que pour arriver à cette
somme est bien il a dû faire ce qu'on
appelle un petit peu enfin additionner
des pommes des poires et des oranges
c'est dire additionner des choses qui ne
sont pas exactement au même niveau
il ya déjà des sommes qui sont sûres et
puis à des sommes qui ne sont pas du
tout sûr donc ça ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est qu'on est
clairement en présence d'une déclaration
politique et il faut le comprendre
alors je n'en fais pas critiques au
ministre mais simplement il ne faut pas
non plus en être complètement du il
s'agit du type de déclaration que l'on a
dans toutes les campagnes électorales
avec ce qu'elles peuvent contenir
outrance ou d'arrangements avec la
vérité ça c'est le deuxième point le
troisième point et c'est peut-être plus
là dessus qu'il faudrait s'intéresser
c'est que évidemment ça nous invite à
remettre la situation de la france en
admettant même que voilà qu'on dépense
effectivement ces 4 124 milliards 4 124
milliards ça représenterait à
après 16 à 17% du pin kung dépensé 4 124
milliards dans les trois années donc
donc de 2020 à 2022 mais combien auront
dépensé les autres pays dans la même
période
et là on verra où on verrait en tous les
cas si on regardait un petit peu les
chiffres que la france certes on a fait
plus que ce qu'on a fait dans certains
autres pays
par exemple les pays d'europe centrale
ont beaucoup moins aidé leurs économies
parce qu'ils n'en ont pas les moyens
mais on en a fait moins que ce qui a été
fait en allemagne en italie et surtout
ce qui est très important ce qui est
fait hors de la zone euro en particulier
en grande-bretagne et aux etats-unis et
donc je crois que c'est ça la leçon
qu'il faut tirer de cette annonce de
chiffres par monsieur olivier dussopt